so you're saying that before you date
the person with the help of your
therapist you quiz them yes me it's like
this Freudian quiz which tells you about
somebody's subconscious do you want to
do it really yeah okay you ask that you
do not think you have to tell me creeps
as long as nothing's getting in my ass
I'm all right cut that okay so the first
thing I need to know is your favorite
animal not your dog not like your
childhood goldfish just your favorite
type of animal your favorite animal yeah
mine was honey badger oh okay that's
that's interesting
I like I think a grizzly bear is so cool
and I need for three reasons why I like
an animal that can kill me I think that
I think they're absolutely amazing I
think they're beautiful looking I've
never seen one in real life I've always
wanted to see a grizzly bear and I love
where they roam they loom around you
know California and Nevada I think
that's really cool yes do you have a
favorite animal yeah I would say an
octopus why because they're like crazy
monsters they are very smart and yeah
they actually are and they actually are
like they actually are very sociable
aren't they as smart as like a
two-year-old human child like that yeah
yeah well when it's a invertebrate any
no one on a late-night talk show has
said what it's an invertebrate
in a long time TBS they want me to class
the place up that's what they said okay
what is your favorite article of
clothing leather jacket leather jacket
give me three reasons why adjectives
three adjectives to describe the leather
jacket worn out huh it's an old friend
sexy I would say like a flannel shirt
like a soft comfy flannel shirt keeps
you warm y-yeah I was trying to speak
them yeah listens to him okay and the
last thing your favorite body of water
okay favorite body of water
okay Creek it could be a pool like you
know I love the Atlantic Ocean great why
I grew up in Boston yeah looking out
three adjectives to describe the
Atlantic Ocean what tumultuous yeah
unpredictable salty no okay so now we
find out about Conan's subconscious the
way that you view yourself is your
favorite animal view yourself as a
grizzly bear because it could kill me I
could I swear to God
there's so many times my life were a
flood of taking me out of the picture
yeah amazing yeah beautiful yeah and I'd
like to see one in real life Matt I've
never seen myself naked yeah
yeah and you view yourself as a crazy
monster yeah smart and sociable yeah
okay and your favorite article of
clothing is how others perceive you
which is usually a nassima to how you
perceive yourself which is where you get
all this other information we don't have
time to get into leather jacket you see
yourself as an old friend
[Music]
[Applause]
okay whatever all right all my friends
think you're hot yeah yeah let's talk to
that brings me to the last one which is
your favorite body of water represents
how you view sex and you view sexes
tumultuous unpredictable
[Applause]
very nicely done you know my body my
body of water would have been dead she
cause it dried up a long time watch Andy
show in Tahoe this week
you